Donald Trump did threaten death and
destruction in a dangerous 1am rant the
other night this is very scary stuff
Trump posting to truth social quote what
kind of person can charge another person
in this case a former president of the
United States who got more votes than
any sitting president in history and
leading candidate by far for the
Republican Party nomination with a
Capital C crime when it is known by all
that no crime has been committed and
also known that potential death and
destruction in such a false charge could
be catastrophic for our Capital C
country why and who would do such a
thing only a degenerate psychopath that
truly hates the USA this is Donald Trump
saying if Alvin Bragg indicts me it will
lead to death and Destruction for the
country and it will be Alvin Bragg's
fault not Trump's fault for inciting the
death and destruction or uh uh I guess
the people who commit the death and
Destruction for listening to Trump
extremely scary stuff the New York Times
reporting Trump escalating attacks
raises Specter of violence if he is
charged
um and mediaite Reporting about Donald
Trump making a post where he's holding a
baseball bat seemingly threatening
himself the district attorney Alvin
Bragg which Trump subsequently deleted I
hope there is not violence but I am very
worried that there will be because of
the direction this is going my only
thought is
it actually seems like Trump supporters
aren't that motivated to go out and
protest and commit commit acts of
violence they seem sort of resigned in a
way let's hope they are lazy and
pacified and don't heed Trump's calls
that's the Hope right now one of our
sponsors is zipix nicotine toothpicks
don't you think it's time you stopped
putting smoke and vape oils in your
lungs zippix toothpicks are a convenient
way to curb the nicotine Cravings zippix
toothpicks are super discreet you can
use them anytime anywhere smoking and
vaping aren't allowed including flights
sporting events in restaurants they're
available in six different flavors with
options of two and three milligrams of
nicotine if you're not a nicotine user
zipix also offers caffeine and b12
infused toothpicks zipx has already
helped 10 tens of thousands of customers
ditch the cigarettes ditch the Vapes
they might be able to help you too if
you're a smoker or a vapor give zipx
toothpicks a try your lungs will thank
you go to zipxtoothpix.com today save
ten percent with the code pacman10 at
checkout just remember you must be 21 or
older to order the link is down below